[Music]
oh no heat the button the buttons live
this is it okay he's going on there no
we need to do it then yeah hi I'm Brian
hey I'm mark and this is the GC podcast
live at Google cloud next actually not
live well it's kind of live the daily
roll up well of the Google cloud next we
recording it live but it will be edited
and then I think we should move to
interviews right away well no wait what
episode number is it Oh number 1 7 1 1
71 here we go hello this is Asha and
we're on the floor at Google cloud next
and I am John and I am excited to be
here with Andre Kelly I'm Andre Kelly
I'm the product manager 1st October I RM
RM stands for instant response and
management so can you tell us a little
bit more about I RM I've heard a lot
about it and I've heard a lot about it
actually internally at Google but I
don't know of external folks I've heard
much about it yet sure so I am vision is
kind of to provide fewer shorter and
smaller outages and the way we try to do
that is through context and continuous
learning one to bring as much context to
the user during the response and then to
caption that response information so
future outages of similar types are
shorter so it's a natural continuous
learning how would developers and
anybody using this would be able to
access this in sure so this a great
question currently extremely rare
available in alpha so you can go to
cloud at google.com slash incident
- response and you'll see a page we can
sign up for the Alpha I heard that we're
using this internally at Google that's a
good point I think I'm understand a
little bit so you should know that iron
started internally and it's really the
next generation Google incident response
set of tools it combines a lot of known
best practices internal to Google a lot
of previous tools that were very
disparate that limited our data
analytics capabilities around incidents
so you can bind it all together and IRM
learning from those best practices and
new ideas about data management how do
we leverage the ops data to help the
user in the investigation process that
relates to sre is using it internally
and our dev arm calls also using it
internally how can developers in like
interacting with a suppose that there
are any issues that they may arise how
can they submit feedback with us we're
always big on getting our feedback from
our developers and making things greater
yes I totally agree and being an alpha
product we're looking for that external
feedback
the product better so the end of tap in
the top right hand corner and all
stackdriver apps there's a button to
submit feedback we also have that
mechanism so and that mechanism take a
screenshot so if there's something you
know hokey going on in the UI it's a
great way to submit that information in
our doctors also email addresses for
contact us that goes straight to the
leaders for the team in terms of issues
you're having or if something seems down
for example I know we're gonna go a
little bit away from the specific
product but you tell us some about SRA
philosophies and how you've brought that
stuff into the start driver tools sure
there's a book for them but one of the
key ones we hone in on is make tomorrow
better hmm
it's just an idea of kind of doing some
work today so tomorrow this kind of work
is easier to do so it's a lot of ways to
go with it
so for an IRM that's the continuous
learning overall this is also about
reducing toil so things that are very
mundane and you do it over and over
again how can we make it automated so
robots do that and that's one of the key
things where we say we bring the context
to you so it was very common in Internet
responses to go look at the chart of the
violetta metric because no one really
believes the alert you have to see it
for yourself to confirm that something
is actually wrong step it to waiting for
the reason and so we just bring that to
you so as soon as you respond do you see
that information and things that are
really related to it so that's part of a
we're making kinda sre tenants come to
life so you are acknowledging the fact
that we are human and we have foibles
and making it's a little - it works with
those trends as opposed to fights
against that's exactly right recognize
the image of humans would you say is the
gem of sree which practice do you
believe would be I think the GEMA
bursary is actually one of the harder
parts of it it's the culture kind of
reflected in SRA but one of the key
things are that culture is a contract
the contract between business developers
and operators that we would believe in
this era budget and we're gonna believe
in Essos and from that developers and
businesses say ok so we know we can push
changes this fast to kind of be
competitive in the market and we know
that if in doing those changes something
breaks we know will stop because we're
liabilities I've got moves
and that's part of the ops kind of you
know charter make sure the applications
available make sure that year users are
happy but it requires that ride like the
Triad to really agree what that means
what the guardrails of that kind of
responsibility is and I think that's one
of the key things about yes every
culture that I think is key to bring
external as well that's awesome so we're
actually already out of time is there
anything that you would like the
listeners to know or a place that they
can find out more about you or about the
tools you're working on so IRM is the
tool and working on as I mentioned we're
an offer and we'll plan to do a lot more
development looking for the feedback
there so please sign up for the Alpha
other things I'm looking forward to is a
stand up how stackdriver continues
tomorrow right kind of internal tooling
and skill sets externally through our
tooling one of the great examples of
that its profiler crews respond GA today
so we're looking forward to build upon
that foundation well thank you so much
for joining us we hope to have you back
you know in a couple months and we can
talk at length about IRM and Incident
Response in SRV best practices that
sounds great looking forward to it thank
you hello this is Asha and we are here
in the GCP podcast housed at Google next
and we have another guest would you like
to introduce yourself
absolutely my name is Anne bertuccio and
I'm on the GCP trust and security
product team that's amazing and our
other hosts here Brian mark cool so
questions your Xu what does that mean on
this you know sometimes I feel like
we're a little bit like the Special
Forces
I'd like to get us glitter gold jackets
let's say trust be very nice could you
do Berets maybe there's friendship I'm
having a hard time with these headphones
in my damn scrolls it's okay but the
trust and security product team so we
really focus on everybody has a
different area
I'm container security for example so my
colleagues are identity threat detection
but we really focus on how do we educate
our GCP users about our security
features and help them understand what
do things do what are they responsible
for that's a big part of it is you know
gke like we have a shared responsibility
model helping people understand here's
what you're responsible for it here's
what GK security products do for you I
think I understood all that
what are we showcasing or talking about
here at next around that
yes about container security
specifically we have the GA of binary
authorization coming soon which is very
exciting so binary authorization is
deployed time controls so that you make
sure that you only deploy container
images that you trust so you can decide
what those attestations are so you know
I wanna make sure this image got scanned
I want to make sure that my QA team took
a peek at it I want to make sure you
know whatever guardrails your
organization needs that's going in your
CI CD system so it's all about that kind
of shifting left mentality rather than
security comes at the end security goes
through the whole thing and we make sure
that you're deploying what you trust
that's an exciting one
we also today this morning announced the
beta for GK sandbox is coming soon and
that one is if you heard G Weiser last
year and Copenhagen Google open-source G
Weiser container isolation based on a
user space kernel that filters syscalls
well a little more complicated than that
that's my nice way of putting I think
the G Weiser team would be cranky with
me but a little you know basically
thinking about how can that user space
kernel handle syscalls so it doesn't get
on to the hosts and we kind of reduced
the tax surface for the host kernel in a
container setup so we now have a
productized version of that in GK so
with one click you can get GK sandbox oh
that's super cool and sounds like the
trust and security team is trying to
make tooling so that people can actually
think about this from start to finish as
opposed to just oh right this is that
security thing we should probably do
that is that like a whole purpose yes oh
that's a big part of our philosophy is
that we have this phrase of security by
default and it's really that you know
out-of-the-box you should not be able to
get yourself into trouble there's always
you know endless configurations that
endless customization but if I just say
go I want to make sure you know my
kubernetes dashboards aren't exposed I
want to make sure my credentials are
locked down those things should come out
of the box
are there any sessions happening around
any of these topics absolutely let's see
if I can remember them all here I think
if you go into the hybrid and containers
you'll find quite a few of them in there
and
we have GK sandbox on Thursday morning
today at 2 o'clock there is one on work
load identity which is about keyless
entry and authentication for your GK
service accounts those problem I -
recommended ones at this point I think
there might also be a couple on the
secure channel of the live stream
excellent very interesting about this
this morning but they'll all go up on
YouTube I'll go up on YouTube and if
yesterday was any indication most of
them should be up within 48 hours
so by the time you hear this they're
probably online at least some of them
will be yes if that's the case I'll make
a plug for one that happened yesterday
which is the who protects what GK's
shared responsibility model I think
that's a really important one for users
to understand here's what you're
responsible for here's what we take care
of for you I believe that we'll be going
on the secure playlist later today
what's been your favorite thing on the
show floor I mean shameless plug is for
the container security demo so the
security showcase we have a container
security demo that been off looking at
you know here's some custom access
stations here's let's actually go
through and stop an attack stop an
untrusted image go back say oh there was
vulnerability that wasn't cleared by my
team we're gonna go back and change that
out so that's in the security showcase
thank you so so much for joining us
having me hey we're here on day two with
brian mark yep and Mary oh hi I'm Gigi
organizer from Munich we run the cloud
community there yeah I'm happy to be
here
awesome well welcome to NEX thank you so
much for joining us what's been a
highlight for you so far here next so
basically two highlights the first
highlight of course was anthos yesterday
but bigger impact if more is for me and
for a lot of our customers is mssql as a
managed database again could be flawed
indeed so I was excited as a - but why
is that interesting to you and your
people we have in Germany a lot of
companies still use ms SQL and have big
ms SQL clusters and moving to cloud is
hard for German companies look at you
regulations of GDP are and privacy and
big companies don't trust renders and
they
to have all bare-metal right but they
start to see that maintaining
infrastructure is expensive and it's
hard to do and they want to move to the
cloud and when you provide managed
service like mssql which is your
database that you used for like 10-15
years
it makes them way more comfortable to
take the step and move into the cloud
fantastic have you seen anything in
particular on the show floor the Evo's I
thought was particularly interesting
yeah I talked to the people from MongoDB
and from elastic and it's cool that
Google tries to team up with the
different databases and search engines
and all of the open-source projects that
are basically out there and try to move
it into the cloud as well as you don't
need another service and another service
and another service provider you can
just have everything on one company all
connected closely synergy is there
anything you'd like to like make sure
more people knew about your work or
cloud or other things
actually there is so we did a lot of
study jumps in the last month to get
people involved in - yeah what is cloud
what is infrastructure and when you do a
show of hands like you have like a room
of 40 people 50 people and you ask them
yeah do you use containers and you get
all of them showing their hands and then
you ask something like to use kubernetes
and you have like three people in the
room showing hands and what the industry
thinks is standard or what many people
say is and like yeah all of the people
use communities it is not the case so
there are a lot of companies especially
that are not so big like one of the big
players but still have a lot of systems
going on and they don't know about the
technology or they afraid of moving the
technology they are because we did it
for 10 years or and we will continue it
the way how we do it and when you show
them things like queue Panetta's or you
show them a service master Fisto where
they can integrate their bare metal
machines bind with remote hosted
machines they love it but they don't
know about it and I think what is our
job to do as communities or expert in
this field is approach to people show
them they are
new ways that make your job easier and
we have provide free trainings like the
Google community starts with quick laps
to just teach people there are cool new
ways there are cool new technologies and
they are not hard to learn but we just
have to go out and get to people to do
it because it's not a thing about yeah
it's only working in Google stuff
because it's everything is open-source
and you can do it and use it wherever
you want and this is really really cool
you mention quick labs but are there any
other particular resources that you
would recommend for people who are
looking to tell like level up as well to
speak on things like that there is
actually a really really nice open
source platform for blogging which is
def dot t-- o-- and it's a really
growing community and you have a lot of
people there that are just started
getting into technology and there are
also a lot of meta articles for
diversity and getting involved in tech
communities and there are a lot of
resources where you can find like how do
I use docker in like to article series
and stuff like this and I think this is
the resources that people should check
out awesome
Debbie oh thank you very much for coming
and taking time to chat with us yeah
thank you for inviting me thank you so
super happy here at the next share floor
to have valentin de la Plus joining us
today to chat about go stuff how you
doing Valentin I'm fine thanks for
having me mark and John me and Valentin
are very good friends so you can just
chat and I'll sit back yeah so Valentin
I I believe you were speaking here next
oh yes I am that's tomorrow so what are
you talking about I'm talking about
performance and the most specifically
performance in go in a public cloud and
more specifically let's say GCP pretty
sure the Gophers are going crazy right
now can we look forward to possibly
seeing you on livestream so that our
external viewers can see you oh yes I've
just got very confidential information
that comes from that
I will be live-streamed nice that's good
that should mean as well like if you're
listening to this later it will be up on
YouTube pretty fast
exactly oh good to know yeah so what
sort of stuff are you covering when you
take performance that seems like a very
big topic what is it that mean to you so
performance is making things faster
especially when things are
little bit too slow and my talk is part
high-level because it's not specific to
go on it's not specific to the cloud
it's sometimes about saving cost and
handling most of both scalability etc
but such Boeing what I'm already talking
about is about improving user experience
by making everything fast snappy that's
the real point because we care about
humans not about machines that's great
and can you give us a sneak peak as to
like what you would consider one of the
more optimal solutions to making things
faster and quicker hot tip I give you
the answer it depends you see the most
important thing is not to have a lot of
prejudice about what is fast what is a
good user experience
you really have to measure to find the
bottleneck and oftentimes it's not where
you think it is and once you have the
bottleneck you work on that and very
often it's possible or even easy to fix
that what are your favorite tools for
like tracking performance metrics or
things like that like how do you observe
this so I love the benchmarking tool
integrated in the go to things that's
really great and then I already we deal
of trace and people it's pretty
mainstream I mean many go developers
already uses and if you're not sure what
the execution tracer is or what people
of eve's then you should definitely come
to my talk tomorrow
excellent what's been your favorite
announcement so far here in X well I
think we can say that cloud one is huge
I mean several S+ containers that is so
great thank you google coming back to
your talk what's the biggest challenge
you see people facing in regards to
performance in regard to their
applications well that's a great
question usually it's a lack of
observability because it's always two
parts first you measure and then you fix
things and observing what is slow and
what is fast is not as obvious as it
sounds so there is tooling some time
it's well integrated and some time it's
a little bit more challenging and what I
witness is
as soon as we've done the first part of
the work that is clear observability
with a nice waterfall view or things
like that then it becomes much more easy
to make the program faster last question
before we let you go is who would you
say your talk is mainly geared towards I
know you said it's more of an experience
talk but we let our viewers know exactly
who should follow on yes so the great
things about cloud and virtual machines
and the several etc that the cloud
components more and more decoupled for
the choice of your language so most of
them you can choose any popular language
and it will work so some folks are using
more and more public clouds and they are
wondering should I use go is it a good
idea will my team of developers use that
and like that and key message that I'm
saying is that go is a really strong and
good choice for cloud computing and I
just don't say it I also demonstrate it
well that's great well don't say thank
you for joining us and really really
look forward to your talk thank you John
thank you mark thank you
well that was a bunch of great
interviews awesome I mean it's super
cool to see the energy it's super cool
to see the people here I think we got a
lot of cool people coming by and just
talking to us about what they like it
next it's just the best thing like all
the people you meet are in the cloud
they're doing amazing things with it
it's fantastic super cool I can't wait
for the next episode okay
[Music]